la tempête de vin qui a frappé une bonne
partie du québec et qui a provoqué donc
ces pannes de courant massive des
racines des arbres aux dégâts également
ça peut donner bien des tracas pour
beaucoup d'entre nous en fait j'en
parlais tout de suite avec louis cyr et
les courtiers en assurance bonjour
monsieur style mais bon nous avons
toujours après la tempête parce que les
assureurs ont enregistré une hausse du
nombre d'appels des gens qui ont aucune
des besoins bien sûr ça a commencé dès
vendredi
il faut comprendre qu'un blues sont la
tempête de vin est couverture de base à
l'ensemble des contrats d'assurance dont
les contrats d'assurance maison
automobiles vont couvrir les dommages
causés par le vent alors les dommages
qu'on avait composé par le vin verres on
peut avoir des parties de bâtiments qui
s'arrache comme vous dites des armes qui
tombe qui brise donc tous les dommages
causés par chute d'objets ou encore
directement par le vin et finalement
même look fait d'être dans une maison
par une toiture arrachée exemple tout
chaud et ou alors tout ce qu'elle va
pourra faire comme dommage dit non parce
que pendant que vous nous parlez on voit
des arbres cassés qui sont tombés sur
des voitures à la lame du voisin qui
tombe sur notre voiture ont découvert
donc oui l'art du voisin qui tombe sur
notre voiture ou une autre résidence là
on s'adresse au niveau de la victime à
son assureur on vous posez vos voisins
et l'autre ont fait si tu m'en faire sur
le sens ça donnerait donc l'assurance
vont indemniser ses propres clients par
mach vitesse que la sueur en voir
poursuivre un voisin quelconque way
uniquement s'il ya négligence et puis
hein quand ici quand ça concerne un
arbre serait en pleine santé qui est
arraché des rats scène par le verre on
parle pas négliger en sicile
on parle de situation catastrophique
donc à ce moment là les assurables
poursuivent pas nécessairement par
contre pour celui qui était pas brillé
tant de la récession c'est ça la trappe
qu'est-ce qui se passe bello à ce moment
alors mon deux roues
le maître le d'éviter finalement et puis
une nouvelle arme que la sueur en europe
et illimité à des petits mental on parle
pas taillé de 5,6 à la cdm auteurs qui
vont permettre de transplanter un jeune
arbre on peut pas transporter les arbres
de 30 40 50
non mais oh mais on est couvert la
sinatra est tombé a fait des dégâts en
seront pas poursuivis oui si on est
poursuivie bien sûr on termine peut-être
là cette séquence là aussi l'assurance
du voisin du poursuit bien on remet
notre mise en demeure à notre assureur
une note rassure en vo nous défendre de
finalement contre l'assurance du voisin
qui veut poursuivre et s'étendre les
deux assureurs qui eux aussi se réglera
à savoir s'il y aura remboursé membres
dont on a parlé des armes il ya toujours
des dégâts qui peuvent survenir dans des
cas comme ça et plusieurs dégâts sur
différents jour là par exemple je pense
à cela qu'ils ont
perdu d'électricité entre autres
confrères une seule réclamations où on
doit faire 2 0 on imite produire une
fiole réclamations aussi on attend lors
du matin pour faire l'arrêt de la
mention on devrait connaître l'ampleur
des dommages
en ce qui concerne par contre les
aliments perdus au niveau des
congélateurs
cette protection l'offre partie de ce
qu'on appelle les garanties
complémentaires dans les contrats de
gérance et cette section du contrôle
faut se rappeler 98 ont fait beaucoup de
parallèles avec leurs bureaux pour 98
là on était en période où les garanties
complémentaires n'était pas sujet à la
franchise du contrat d'assurance
or les gens pouvaient rien hormis les
montants du comté la table dès le 1er
d'alors maintenait les formulaires ont
changé suite à 98 et le contenu des
congélateurs les gammes si
complémentaires sont sujets à la
franchise donc si on en trois ans 100 ou
500 ballons sur son lit mon tacon
devront débourser avant d'avoir accès à
nos réalisations d'autres assurables
donc les contrats d'assurance ont changé
la couverte les couvertures ont changé
depuis la crise du verglas
ouais mais c'est simplement leur à ce
niveau là la franchise qui s'applique
aux garanties complémentaires et les
conduit quand jonathan ou plutôt la
panne d'électricité fait partie des
garanties complément et comment on
évalue les pertes qu'on peut avoir eu
d'aliments réjouit éric aujourd'hui
s'effacer l'on paie presque tous avec
une 4 des terrains ou une carte de grise
si les assure un vent marin délits
relevés des épiceries vont demander en
ce2 john la liste des aliments qu'on a
acheté dans les derniers terre et bien
sûr on peut parler de leurs muscles pour
payer alors tout ce qu'on a payée par
virement électronique
ben les assureurs ont l'ensemble des
biens achetés assez facilement alors non
pas on soumet soit l'assureur et
l'assuré nous était venu en train on
prend des photos je mange en avant
d'acheter ça à la poubelle
d'autres choses qu'on aurait oublié là
peut-être les entreprises 1 il ya
certains commerces qui ont quand même
subi d'importants dommages alors pour
ces gens là la couverture de pannes des
services publics dont l'électricité est
parti il est souvent sujette à ce qu'on
appelle un délai de franchise et non pas
un montant de franchise donc souvent ces
gens là vont faire face à 36 48 72
heures de panne avec l'assureur paie
l'ensemble des autres le dommage alors
que la panne actuelle on répétait pas
durer 72 heures dans bien des commerces
malheureusement cette protection le
lorsqu'on voit s'adresse à son monsieur
on pourrait avoir ce type de découverte
l'eau mais sachez que c'est normal et
tous les contrats d'assurance se
comporte alors on prend des photos
ensemble ap d'assurance on appelle notre
assureur et voilà essai toulonnais l'eau
il n'y a pas vraiment d'exclusion le
haut niveau des tempêtes nous essaiera
courtiers d'assurances merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec merci à vous